.
>> Sean: THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
NOT LIBERAL ANYMORE.
INSTEAD THEY'RE A FAR LEFT GROUP
OF WOKE ELITISTS THAT WANT TO
TRANSFORM AMERICA INTO THEIR
COMMUNAL WE CAN EQUITY-BASED
SOCIETY THAT THEY CONTROL,
RULING WITH AN IRON FIST FROM
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IN THEIR PERFECT WORLD, THERE'S
NO DISSENT, NO INDIVIDUALISM, NO
FREEDOM, NO CHECKS, NO BALANCES.
JUST ONE-PARTY RULE IN
PERPETUITY FOREVER AND FOREVER.
LET'S GET THE REACTION TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS ABOUT
THE HURRICANE, EQUITY, AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR.
>> I'LL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW,
SHE'S PLAYING RACE POLITICS.
SHE'S A RACIST.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE OF ALL DIFFERENT
COLORS OUT THERE WHO HAVE
SUFFERED FROM THAT HURRICANE.
ALL SHE FOCUSES ON, RACE?
THAT'S WHY SHE'S VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE WASN'T ELECTED AS VICE
PRESIDENT ON SKILL.
IT'S BECAUSE OF HER SKIN COLOR
AND GENDER.
THAT'S THE GAME SHE PLAYS
EVERYWHERE.
IT'S SICKENING AND INSULTING.
KAMALA HARRIS SPEAKS, NOT FOR
MINORITY PEOPLE.
SHE SPEAKS FOR KAMALA HARRIS.
THE NONMINORITY WHO HAVE
SUFFERED IN FLORIDA, IT'S
OUTRIGHT INSULTING, EMBARRASSING
SHE USED HER COLOR AND GENDER AS
A SHIELD FROM ATTACK.
FROM THIS CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY,
SHE'S THE FARTHEST FROM BEING A
PERSON WHO LOOKS AT PEOPLE
WITHOUT REGARDS TO COLOR.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, LET ME ASK
YOU, CLAY, BECAUSE WHEN RON
DESANTIS SAID WE'RE A SECOND
AMENDMENT STATE, WHAT HE'S
SAYING IS, FOR ALL OF YOU OUT
THERE THAT LIVE IN STATES, HAVE
THE MENTALITY OF DEFUND THIS
MANTEL, NO BAIL, THAT DOESN'T GO
OVER WELL IN THIS STATE, WE
BELIEVE IN LAW AND ORDER, SAFETY
AND SECURITY, AND PEOPLE HAVE A
RIGHT TO DEFEND THEMSELVES,
THEIR FAMILIES, THEIR PROPERTY.
I DON'T EVEN DEEM IT
CONTROVERSIAL.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE BREAKING INTO
SOMEBODY'S HOUSE AND TRYING TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF A NATURAL
DISASTER.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
>> NO DOUBT.
AND KAMALA HARRIS, FRANKLY, IS A
DISGRACE.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING LEO
SAID.
WHAT WE'VE DONE FOR GENERATIONS
IN THIS COUNTRY IS WHEN THERE
ARE NATURAL DISASTERS, DO YOU
KNOW WHERE WE GO?
TO THE PEOPLE WHO NEED THE HELP
THE MOST.
THE PEOPLE MOST IN DANGER,
WHETHER THEY'RE WHITE, BLACK,
ASIAN, HISPANIC, GAY, STRAIGHT,
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS.
WE DON'T CARE.
AND WE ALSO DON'T CARE WHO THE
LOOTERS ARE.
WE CAN'T HAVE THEM, PERIOD.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THEM TO BE BAILED
OUT LIKE KAMALA HARRIS WAS DOING
IN THE SUMMER OF 2020 WHEN ALL
OF THOSE PROTESTS THAT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO REAP THE
CONSEQUENCES OF TOOK OVER IN OUR
COUNTRY.
IT'S NOT A COINCIDENCE THAT
MURDERS ARE UP 40% ALL OVER THIS
NATION SINCE THE SUMMER OF 2020.
IT'S BECAUSE DEMOCRATS LIKE
KAMALA HARRIS DECIDED THAT
AMERICA WAS AN AWFUL RACIST
PLACE AND THE ONLY WAY THEY
COULD BE IN POWER WAS BY TELLING
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC LIES.
AND EVERYBODY IS WAKING UP NOW,
FIVE WEEKS FROM THIS MIDTERM,
AND PEOPLE LIKE KAMALA HARRIS,
WHO ARE STILL TRYING TO PEDDLE
THIS CRAP, ARE GOING TO FRANKLY
GET THEIR ASS KICKED ALL OVER
THIS COUNTRY, INCLUDING IN
FLORIDA, WHERE, LET'S BE HONEST,
SEAN, THIS ATTACK IS NOT ABOUT
RON DESANTIS DISCUSSING THE
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS OF
FLORIDIANS.
IT'S BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO WIN A
LANDSLIDE ELECTION IN FLORIDA.
HE BARELY WON IN 2018.
THEY THREW EVERYTHING THEY HAD
AT HIM DURING COVID.
I'M HAPPY TO BE A HOMEOWNER IN
FLORIDA.
I KNOW YOU'VE GOT A PLACE THERE
TOO, SEAN.
RON DESANTIS GOT EVERYTHING
RIGHT ABOUT COVID.
THEY'RE NOW TRYING TO USE THE
HURRICANE TO ATTACK HIM.
THEY'RE GOING TO FAIL.
I THINK HE'S GOING TO WIN BY
DOUBLE DIGITS AS LONG AS
FLORIDIANS HIT THE POLLS.
WITH WHEN THAT HAPPENS, THERE
ARE A LOT OF DEMOCRATS THAT WILL
BE CURLED UP IN THE FETAL
POSITION, CRYING BECAUSE THEY
HATE HIM, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN
RIGHT ABOUT EVERYTHING WITH
COVID, WITH SCHOOL, AND HE'S
GOING TO DO, I BELIEVE, A GREAT
JOB HELPING OUT BLACK, WHITE,
ASIAN, HISPANIC, EVERYBODY, WHO
WAS IMPACTED BY THIS STORM, AS
HE SHOUL